لقد توصلنا بهدوء إلى اتفاق مع
كاتا لتوسيع العمليات في
أكبر قاعدة عسكرية أمريكية في الشرق الأوسط،
وفقًا لثلاثة من مسؤولي الدفاع الأمريكيين
ومسؤول آخر مطلع على
الصفقة، كانت قاعدة ألادي الجوية
مركزًا محوريًا للقيادة المركزية الأمريكية
للعمليات الجوية.  في جميع
أنحاء المنطقة، من المقرر أن يغطي التمديد
10 سنوات أخرى، ولم يتم
الإعلان عن الصفقة علنًا، لكنها تسلط الضوء على
اعتماد واشنطن على الدولة الخليجية الصغيرة، كما
سنتحدث عن مراسلة سي إن إن للأمن القومي
ناتاشا بيترون في
البنتاغون، ولست متأكدة من أنه كان هناك  هناك
الكثير من الاقتراحات بأن هذا لن
يستمر أه ولكن ماذا نعرف في هذه
المرحلة، نعم بيكي، لذا توصلت الولايات المتحدة وقطر إلى
اتفاق أه بهدوء شديد
ودون أي إعلان عام بأن الولايات
المتحدة ستقوم بتوسيع
الجيش الأمريكي  التواجد في هذه
القاعدة العسكرية المترامية الأطراف في قطر لمدة 10
سنوات أخرى والسبب الملحوظ في ذلك هو
بالضبط كما قلت،
لم يكن هناك حقًا أي شك في أن الولايات المتحدة لن
تجدد هذه الصفقة، فهي
منشأة عسكرية مهمة للغاية بالنسبة
للولايات المتحدة.  يمكن أن تستوعب أكثر من 10000
جندي، وخاصة الآن ونحن نرى
التوترات تتصاعد في جميع أنحاء المنطقة
مع كل هذه الضربات التي تشنها إيران
بدعم وكلاء في العراق وسوريا واليمن، فمن
المنطقي تمامًا أن ترغب الولايات المتحدة في
الحفاظ على وجودها في قطر ولكن الأمر
المثير للاهتمام  جزء من هذا هو أن الولايات المتحدة
لم تعلن ذلك علنًا
لم يكن هناك حفل أه عام أه
حفل توقيع على سبيل المثال من شأنه تمديد
عقد الإيجار أو تجديده وذلك في
المقام الأول لأنه قيل لنا أن الولايات المتحدة
كانت مترددة جدًا في نوع من الدعاية
و  تلعب هذا الجانب من
علاقتها بالقارئين
تعرض القاري لبعض الانتقادات
هنا في أمريكا بسبب استضافتهم أه بعض
قادة حماس خلال الأشهر الماضية
أه منذ هجوم 7 أكتوبر
تلك الدعوات بالطبع تتزايد
أه لطرد حماس  من قطر والولايات المتحدة
كانت أه حريصة على ليس بالضرورة أن
تنأى بنفسها عن قطر ولكن ليس
بالضرورة أيضًا أه كما تعلم أخبر
الجمهور الأمريكي أنهم
سيزيدون وجودهم العسكري
هناك ويمددونه أه لمدة 10
سنوات أخرى هذا ليس شيئًا  أه
بالضرورة أه يحظى بشعبية كبيرة في الولايات المتحدة
الآن، لذلك من الواضح أن كوتار كان
شريكًا رئيسيًا للغاية مع الولايات المتحدة فيما يتعلق
بمفاوضات الرهائن سواء كان ذلك في
إسرائيل أو في فنزويلا مؤخرًا أم
لكن هذا شيء تراه الولايات المتحدة
مهمًا جدًا أه لكن  من الجدير بالذكر أنهم
لم يقرروا نشر الأمر
حتى
الآن، دعونا نذكر أنفسنا، أعني
أنكم تعلمون أن مكتب حماس افتتح،
بدعم من و،
وسيقول البعض بناء على طلب من
الإدارة الإعلانية الأمريكية